this morning in our eye on earth series
we're walking among giants not the
mythical creatures but ancient trees the
huge sequoia groves of California draw
millions of tourists a year but these
forests are more than photo
opportunities their longtime warriors in
the battle against climate change
Jonathan Vigliotti climbed with
scientists to dizzying heights to see
how the changing climate may be taking
its toll good morning were here in the
Sequoia National Park perched upon one
of the largest trees in the world which
just so happens to be a cloud hugging
laboratory for scientists studying the
impacts of climate change from the air
the breathtaking beauty of the Sierra
Nevada covers up an ugly statistic the
Forest Service estimates that about a
hundred and thirty million trees died in
the state of California during this
drought 130 million 130 million from a
lack of water yeah tree ecologists
Anthony Ambrose and Wendy Baxter have
been working throughout that drought
which lasted from late 2010 to earlier
this year but they haven't been studying
the pines firs and Cedars that died
they've been analyzing the world-famous
monsters that survived the giant
sequoias the largest living creatures on
earth they've been living and growing in
the same place some of them for
thousands of years but even these giants
have an Achilles heel yeah their demand
for water we've measured that an
individual giant sequoia tree uses up to
a thousand gallons of water in a single
day if that water supplied to the
miche's and there's got to be an impact
on the trees eventually really puts
everything into perspective yeah doing
science way out here means more than
just as strenuous hike in fact that's
just the beginning most of the action is
happening up in the canopies that's
where all the leaves are so you had to
go up we had to go up since 2015
they've been scaling trees like this one
250 feet high in order to record the
drought
packed on their health and growth on
this day they brought me along for the
climb how many times at your peak were
you climbing up a tree so I think my
record for one day was seven climbs
seven climbs high above Ambrose got to
work downloading data from a science
station they previously installed the
side branches need to be cut fairly
close yes well Wendy gathered branch
samples to be examined back in a lab it
took a little over an hour but I
eventually joined the pair and the
deceptive safety of the trees canopy
kind of a terrifying place to be doing
some signs
what has your data you've collected so
far what does the data told you they are
really good at minimizing how much water
they lose under drought conditions by
shutting down the little tiny pores in
their leaves those tiny pores are also
what allows them to absorb carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere it sounds
like they're shut down for business yeah
yeah so they don't take up as much
carbon dioxide and that's troubling for
two reasons the less carbon dioxide
trees capture and store the more of the
heat-trapping gas that stays in the
atmosphere fueling global warming also
the trees use carbon dioxide as food to
grow Ambrose and Baxter have also taken
from the Sequoias core samples basically
long thin strips of wood from deep
inside the tree they can use to
determine its age and growth labs are
still analyzing them but some of those
cores are already telling the story so
these three lines very close together
indicate not a lot of growth in that
period exactly yeah exactly the climate
is changing so what does that mean for a
tree like the Sequoia that has very
specific needs in order to survive the
way that
for so long yeah every organism has
thresholds that they can't survive as it
gets hotter snow is going to melt
earlier and there's going to be less
water available for these trees and it
may not be a place that they can
continue to grow into the future many of
these trees have been alive since before
the Roman Empire which means
civilization literally grew up around
them Ambrose and Baxter are now studying
the impacts that civilization is having
on these trees very existence concept
think about that you know pretty good
interview location the deceptive safety
of the canopy or the fact that those
trees know how to shut themselves down
in order to survive and then the people
that are doing the work the passion that
they have to have to do this well it's
those trees yeah but they need as they
said up to a hund thousands of water a
day for one tree